Biden's legal drama reaching a bit of a
Tipping Point today Republicans getting
a chance to grill Kevin Morris he is the
Hot Shot lawyer from Hollywood so-called
sugar brother who has been making it
rain for the first Sun Morris reportedly
paying at least $5 million in Hunter's
tax bills housing legal fees according
to a report he told house investigators
that he had visited the White House
three times while bankrolling the first
family he's also paying Hunter's ex-wife
and the mother of his young out of wed
lock daughter Morris denies that there
is any political motivation for any of
this saying in part quote I do not I did
not and do not have any expectations for
receiving anything from Hunter's father
or the bid Administration my only goal
was and is to help my friend and client
meanwhile Hunter is ending his months of
defiance after finally agreeing to a
private deposition behind closed doors
with House Republicans that's going to
happen now on February the 28th it's a
major shift after he was seen pulling
two political stunts one of which were
which where he showed up for his
deposition only to blow it off and Bash
the
investigation there is no fairness or
decency in what these Republicans are
doing they have lied over and over about
every aspect of my personal and
professional life so much so that their
lies have become the false facts
believed by too many people H remember
that then he showed up at the other
hearing uh and then when it got too
heated in there and people said things
he didn't like he got up and walked out
and who was with him when he got up and
walked out Kevin Morris uh Janine I'm
gonna start with you on this um you know
this is his his friend I mean I I would
love to know or maybe I actually don't
want to know um the inside of this
relationship months after they met in
2019 he started paying off all of his
bills and and I just see a pattern here
of you know befriending buking dumping
and then getting angry I how long do it
take takes before these two start
scrapping at each other and Kevin Morris
starts telling different stories you
know I I don't know here's what I do
know I mean they're talking about maybe
almost $7 million and by the way I just
have to make a comment for Hunter Biden
talking about the Republicans not having
any decency for this guy to even have
the word decency coming out of his mouth
and we've seen every part of his body
that we don't want to see is really
stunning the G of that man
not the
balls okay all right so here here's the
thing I don't really care about Kevin
Morris the only thing I care about he's
a lawyer for the for the people who who
write South Park is he purchased Hunter
share or stake in a china-backed
investment uh during Joe Biden's first
year allowing the first family to claim
that they had divested themselves of any
connection to communist Chinese money
and so he buys or gets his share and
then then he gives them money I mean
that's a problem for me but other than
that I could care less about this guy
but Charlie I'm just intrigued I mean
who why is this guy doing all of this
why is he trying to clear the decks for
100 B he's buying all of his artwork
after they only knew each other for a
few months yeah anytime you're defending
a sugar brother in politics you're
losing badly um it's but what's really
strange about it is that this this
actually may be the least terrible
Scandal that the Biden family uh faces I
love his statement talking about how he
had no expectation of something in
return for all of his money which sort
of reminds us of all the other areas
where a hunter Biden was collecting
money from China Ukraine
Mexico you know all these different
places where and and they're saying oh
no of course there was no expectation of
something in return yes there was it
kind of makes you wonder whether or not
there's it's like it's almost like
they're trying to the White House wants
to talk about this because they don't
want to talk about these other things
where Joe Biden is completely involved
in and then of course you have the
advance the the White House Advance Team
sent uh Joe Biden out to go speak today
at a um High School Unfortunately they
picked a hunter high school and so look
at the the entire time she's talking
she's standing behind a hunter High
hunter tennis so I'm starting to think
that maybe the White House maybe the
White House has turned on Hunter High
hunter High man yeah Piers what do you
think I can't get past the art so I
agree with you I don't really care about
this guy at Morris except that he paid
$850,000
300 grand in cash the rest in loans that
she didn't expect to get back to Hunter
Biden for his art now my mother has a
degree in Fine Art which she got in her
60s to her great uh talented Delight uh
this is Hunter Biden's art I would
probably pay possibly at my local flea
market $10 maybe 15 do you know how much
it goes for it goes for between 2 200
and
$500,000 a piece some of this stuff
right for utter garbage so if you could
get that for $10 you would buy it no
possibly where would you put it right so
he's obviously not a proper artist and
yet why is this guy paying all this
money why is he paying off his loans why
is he doing all this stuff obviously
he's doing it for political access he
met Hunter Biden at a Biden fundraiser
he's been to the White House three times
and met Joe Biden this guy is Hollywood
hot shot he smokes his bongs he goes to
see South Park because he works for them
and he pops along to the White House and
hey I'm in with the president that's why
he's doing this and that's why like
everything like everything
inv kind of this is a love story like
we're all adults here and I have some I
want to with him to the there no I got
like 20 there's like no such thing as a
sugar brother it's his sugar daddy and
it's a love story if this was Hallmark
we all have tissues tears in our eyes so
let's just call it what it is no every
guy who's made the mistake of putting a
stripper through college and never gets
anything back knows that that sometimes
love is oneid so that's all that this is
It's Just A Love Affair you know just
call it what it is who's the stripper in
this situation Hunter
okay clearly a man with no decency well
that's we don't know that to be true but
you know what love is cuz nothing else
is going to make a man friendship it's a
beautiful thing it's a they met it's a
wonderful beautiful friendship hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else